peta murgatroyd flaunts her glistening
baby bump feels good
the 30 year old dancing with the stars
pro and her fiance Maksim Chmerkovskiy
are expecting a baby boy in January and
Peeta often posts her growing bellies
progress to social media on Thursday she
posted this scandalous shot of her and
her bump in a black bra and underwear
all oiled up writing in the caption
oiling this Buttercup up 33 weeks boom
voilà Peeta and Max have been preparing
for their new bundle of joy with diaper
changing drills I was supposed to be
super simple myself his butt like goes
right here but go bang bang bang bang
and then this goes and that goes boom my
mom oh look we give it ET spoke with the
daddy to be in September where he gushed
over becoming a father I'm already
thinking about the spoils and i get i
get the what is that thing called the
strap thing that he's just want baby
bjorn I just wanted to live right here
till is about like seven years old and
you know until he's like that I don't
want to be here
you